الاخوان بيزون بتمان
الاخوان
ذكائهم في التعدد
الجباتهم او جبابهم واحنا في تونس هنالك
الانجليزيه
الجبه الاوروبيه الجبه المشيقيه الزب
الاخوانيه يعني
التنظيميهم في تلك الجبائب
النظام النظام
يمكن ان نقول رماهم لكن دون ان ان يكون في
الكلمه يعني معنى سلبي لان رمتهم افعالهم
هم شاركوا بعد سبع نوفمبر
الميثاق الوطني
وامض على المحافظه على مكاسب الدوله في
الحريات العامه وفي وضعيات المراه
التونسيه وفي بناء الديمقراطي وخصوصا في
فصل الدين على الدوله على اساس ان الدين
شان شخصي وشان عقائدي هم حريه الاشخاص
وشان يحميه الدستور وتتولى شؤونه الدوله
لانني كنت في الحياه السياسيه
حتى قبل 87
لاني جئت من حزب كان في المعارضه زمن
بورقيبه اللي هو حركه الديمقراطين
للسيارات فيها اكثر النساء خمس سنوات
وانا من عائله وطنيه من عائله
السجون الى اخره
وايضا من عائله اجتماعيه لان كان فيها
نقابيين وانا ايضا كنت نشد نقابه ماذا
تريد ان تقول اريد ان اقوله انه في كل تلك
المراحل عندما يفتح المجال الاتجاه
الاسلامي سابقا الذي اصبح النهضه
منذ سبعينات قام باعمال مشاغبه واعمال
العنف سنه 77 في الفنادق السياحيه في
الساحل سندت 81
تحركات تلمابيه في الشوارع وحاول ان ان
يستغل شباب صغار يعني شباب المدارس
في سنه 88
ورحب بقدوم بن علي
التسلل سلطان
ولكن رغم ذلك رغم ذلك صارت اشياء يعني في
الميدان رجعنا الى ماء الفرق على وجوه بعض
الائمه الى اعتداءات حتى وصلنا سندت 91
الى عمليه باب سويقه التي اعترفوا بها
المرحوم بن سالم الذي كان وزيرا من من
النهضه في التعليم العالي صرح بذلك بشكل
يعني واضح وغيره من القيادين وحتى من
المشاركين في تلك العمليه
وبالتالي تلك الاعمال
مع ما جرى فيما بعد عند جارتنا الشقيقه
الجزائر العشريه السوداء التي تسقط فيها
ضحايا كثيرون من الابرياء والمدنيين
والنساء والاطفال الى اخره
ولجا خلالها الى بلادنا الكثير من اشقائنا
الجزائريين الذين هددوا في حياتهم باسم
الجهاد الديني باسم كذبه كل هذه الظروف
امني او فيه تشدد لكن التشدد كل مكان يرفض
فيه هو التجاوزات ووقعت تجاوزات
وحسبت احيانا ولم تحاسب احيانا